[Music]
what's up reject nation in his eye
Donald M Humphrey coming at you with me
today is Keaton Marquis of Keaton
marquee Fame yeah follow her on social
media show her some love
Keaton have you seen the new venom movie
Tom Hardy oh well you're gonna be seeing
a lot more venom pretty soon I would
imagine because they just made stupid
money at the box they have me you know
they really didn't need me to buy that
ticket they did okay I'm gonna see it
eventually because obviously Tom Hardy
but I don't know maybe you may you never
know or maybe other characters are in it
who you know could be equally as
exciting as one of the most important
parts of Venom's origin story I was like
you mean spare me yeah yes honestly at
this point I have no idea what the
future holds because like with the
amount of money they just made it and
the fact that like you can almost
guarantee you see what will happen
who knows maybe Marvel will open up that
door in a couple of you want to see it
even more now that I've gotten like the
feedback from people about it because my
friends like you even said it's not good
but Tom Hardy's great but it's so
enjoyable yeah like it's so much fun to
watch I'm always down for a movie that's
a fun ride yeah well hey we're gonna get
more fun rides in the future that's why
I thought this video would be fun
because it's the 10 nicest things venom
has ever done and hey I mean that was a
big thing about the new movie venom is a
lot friendlier than you know he is as a
villain so I figure maybe something in
this video is gonna have some clues as
to what we can expect in the future but
before we hop into that just really
quick want to thank everybody who has
joined us on patreon lately got a Hulk
really appreciate you guys over there we
do a whole bunch of exclusive content
including full-length TV show reactions
for stuff such as Riverdale Gotham
supernatural a Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood attack on Titan and my hero
academia we also do weekly q and A's a
lot of great people over there so would
love it if you come check us out also
patron of the day shout out for Derek
Mitchell at the end of this video you
ready to hop into this yeah let's get
some venom on let's do this
oh yeah yeah you want to hear this this
is important is there spoilers in this
this could help in a geek too I don't
think so unless you're really concerned
about I really like could the comic
books I'm fine
I'll be okay all right here we go I'm
counting on you
Venna may have a bad reputation but he's
done more than a few good deeds welcome
to watchmojo.com and today we're
counting down our picks for the top 10
nicest things venom has ever done before
we begin we publish new content every
day so be sure to subscribe to our
Channel and ring the bell to get
notified about our latest do it ring
that bell ring that mojo bell for this
list we're looking at the times where
the anti-hero took a break from crime
and embraces heroic instincts yes the
only be focusing on those who has
learned the original Venom symbiote so
heroic acts from characters like
anti-venom won't be included on this
list since some of these good deeds are
connected to major plot points spoiler
warning is in effect number 10 protected
Peter Parker's parents amazing
spider-man volume 1 number 375 venom
tends to believe that spider-man ruins
people's lives the answer girl was one
so convinced of his belief that he
kidnapped Peter Parker's parents to keep
them away from the webhead when
spider-man tries to get him back from
venom they're all attacked by a group of
mercenaries the wild Meili results in
Peters parents being surrounded by
flames
despite fire being one of Venom's only
weaknesses he leaves through the flames
to save the Parkers while we can't
defend Venom's choice to kidnap Peters
parents the risky took recipe them shows
that his heart was well somewhat in the
right that's the sequel I burn I'm soft
eating brain cross items but hunger
number 3 we should always try to be
respectful of other people's dietary
needs
however we completely understand why
Eddie Brock was horrified when he
discovered that the Venom symbiote
developed a craving for a nutrient found
in people's brains when Brock refuses to
go on the zombie diet the symbiote
separates from him and goes on a brain
depowering rampage Venom's hunger gets
so bad that it almost devours its host
fortunately Brock discovers that the
nutrient the symbiote wanted could be
found in chocolate heroes and villains
like the bubbly thankfully item stopped
performing violent neuro surgery and
settled for chocolate bars I want
number eight defended aliens across the
galaxy venice basement numbers one
through thirteen when the former
highschool bully Flash Thompson first
bonded with the living Venom symbiote he
was warned about its violent influence
but after a trip to the symbiotes home
planet the two decided that Venom's
should leave behind his dark past and
protect others by becoming an agent of
the cosmos in Venom's new position wait
Steve civilization makes new allies
I hope so the beings find their true
purpose that was with his violent urges
he makes an effort to rise above them
Venom's decision to fight villains and
save strangers despite having darkened
stings sounds like a choice a hero would
make number seven stopped a deadly
plague venom licensed to kill number
three after Eddie Brock committed dozens
of crimes as venom an American agent
entered
IRA's criminal record if he worked for
the government Rock goes undercover to
stop an evil doctor from unleashing a
deadly plague since venom has orders to
keep his powers hidden until he finds
the source of the plague he nearly dies
during the mission but his obedience
pays off when he's taken to the doctor's
base and puts an end to the infectious
disease while this successful mission
didn't make up for his past crimes it
was a step in the right direction for
venom number 6 earthquake victim in
credible Hulk vs venom Oh villain named
dr. bad vibes yes ha ha right San
Francisco with an earthquake when the
city starts shaking venom leaps into
action to save as many people as he can
his most hilariously heroic moment comes
when he arrives just in time to save a
couple in a car from falling into a
fiery sinkhole after one of them
complains about the damaged venom get to
the vehicle he drops the car into the
sinkhole
although dr. Bob Ives later turns out to
be a phony villain taking credit for
random earthquakes and a narrow ism is
completely authentic number 5 Mary Jane
and I are nature's amazing spider-man is
volume 1 and I wouldn't love it the
spacious carnage symbiote was created
when a piece of venom attached itself to
the intense
real killer Cletus Kasady that symbiotes
latched itself onto Norman Osborn
resulting villain rat Goblin became a
powerful Menace dr. Osborn tears through
all spider-man's allies J jonah Jameson
asked Eddie Brock to join the fight
although Mary Jane Watson initially
attacks venom when he arrives to help
and still protects her from the red
Goblin
although venom has fought the statistics
can be up on numerous occasions because
of its importance help red goblin could
have taken Mary Jane's life number 4
went undercover as a nun the church is
the last place you'd expect to see venom
but when the government asked him to go
undercover to protect a forum president
from terrorists he put on his Sunday
best scheme and by that we mean that
venom literally dressed like a nun to
blend in for his mission once his
superiors gave the signal stopped a gun
yielding terrorists from threatening
hostages venom even helps to offer the
origins unfortunately his violent
approach to stopping the terrorists
taught him in trouble with Ghost Rider
despite the two antihero Nicolas Cage
what skulls are fairly good number three
ended a student venom license to kill
number one during Venom's early days as
an unofficial government agent his
superior had a bomb planted in his chest
he was born that it could be detonated
out of control sure jury a shootout
erupted between two drug dealers
although his superiors tell him to stand
down and ignore the violence he leaps
into the fray and brings a brutal end to
the shooting Venom's actions could have
caused a trigger-happy government agent
to blow him up on the spot but he was
unable to let senseless violence
continue while he had the power to stop
it
number two mentored Andy Benton venom
number 39 high school student Andy
Benton discovered that her gym teacher
Flash Thompson was secretly banana Oh
where'd you go I speak with him the
villainous jack-o'-lantern arrives
during his hence battle mentioned
murders Andy's father
Wendell uses a symbiote to protect Andy
a piece latches on and turns her into a
being called mania mania tries to kill
Lantern for revenge but venom convinces
her to spare his life after that fateful
night he continues to protect mania and
prevents her from taking a dark path
then it may not seem like an ideal
mentor but he truly under no he does
what Andy is going through number one
safeguarded an underground city venom
lethal protector numbers 126 lethal
protector story a new snarky San
Francisco
however he can't stop a mugging without
murdering crooks venom gets his chance
to be better when he witnessed his
homeless people being attacked after
defending them he discovers they have an
underground city that's being threatened
by a cruel businessman although they
refused his help
venom plates numerous villains and
undergoes tremendous pain to save their
lives
what makes his actions truly heroic is
that there was no promise of a reward
they wanted to help the people in need
do you agree with our thanks check out
these other great clips from WatchMojo
and be sure to subscribe L to be
notified I agree with these pics because
I have no other pics to drop and yeah I
mean it clearly as evidenced by this and
I mean - with the whole chocolate
loophole I'm gonna say I'm like now all
I want a strapless well that yeah and
and I mean venom you know as long as
he's on the chocolate diet he could be
an even better hero you know ain't gotta
eat people chocolate makes me happy
hey yeah if you want to start recording
you can just have some shot can we add
some chocolate well yeah I mean my
hunger for brains is easily sated this
could be a perfect tie-in for the movie
- because you could have like Eddie
Brock
turn into venom and get really angry and
stuff and then like Daniel Vito comes by
it's like whoa whoa venom you're not
yourself when you're hungry and then eat
snicker isn't perfect like by Danny
DeVito cuz Danny DeVito is Amin in M&Ms
commercials
you want penguin to come I'm trying to
mash up all the villains into one candy
bar universe but this kind of made me
wish that they would stop making venom
movies and just make some kind of venom
TV show where every week I get to see it
one of these scenarios depicted like a
Dexter asked show wouldn't be cool that
would be cool because then you're gonna
have him being Eddie Brock doing like
investigative journalism during the day
and then venom just eating yes yes next
chocolate and doesn't do anything else
he's not he's neither a lethal protector
or a lethal villanies just a lethal lazy
guy this is a lethal chocolatier
honestly I think this number 10 one is
my favorite because how awesome would
that be if the third Marvel's spider-man
movie and then like the second or third
Sony venom movie crossover for this
weirdness where venom like kidnaps
Peter's parents you'd have to do some
weird right retro like Peters parents
right now are not Canon in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe because that man yeah
but who knows what's gonna happen after
infinities whatever for Avengers poor I
know really glad they did because I
thank you such a cool villain I'm gonna
be really stoked for him to come back in
future could at some point in some
spider-man movie it's not gonna be the
next one but I think it's gonna be maybe
the following one a lot of those
villains are gonna escape
like I know Sony wanted to do like a
sinister six for a long time and then
you know you get Home Coming where you
have both the vulture and then you get
that little tease with the Scorpion and
you also have shocker around
mm-hmm so like I can definitely see I
feel like it would be a bummer for Sony
if Marvel just came and it was like hey
you know that thing you were trying to
do where we're gonna do it right now
we're gonna make it work
but I could definitely see it happening
for sure especially as I don't know how
many notes like Marvel takes from DC or
whatever but it seems like more and more
group based super hero and villain
movies are coming down the pike well
they have enough money now because they
all these people and I mean now it's
funny because DC stole Tim Gunn I mean
Tina shames make it work make it work
suicide scumbag DC you stole James gun
Jimmy good night the new Suicide Squad
movie as well as potentially directed
hasn't been confirmed yet but this could
be kind of a thing that they start
I just appreciate that this whole
chocolate thing that's all giving up
brains thing keep an eye out during the
new film it's not like a major moment
but I realized they do nod to that in
the movie yeah yeah it's fun I think you
will enjoy it especially if you think
Eddie Brock is hot cuz you know Tom
Hardy he doesn't have the mullet you're
gonna be disappointed in that
no no mullet no McGee do I want t-shirt
no me
I feel like this intergalactic again
there's so much discussion and debate
about venom without spider-man and Sony
and Marvel aren't getting along and they
wanted to maybe cross them over but
they're not gonna do but I feel like the
number-8 one here defending aliens
across the galaxy could be a cool way to
incorporate him into the MCU if they
wanted to
guardians yeah that's the first thing I
thought even in one of these photos in
this video I thought I saw a moral
especially with the amount of humor the
movie has I could definitely see him at
least not being entirely out of clay the
only thing is like venom Eddie Brock
like is pretty terrestrial characters
the only thing I would have to get used
to is him in space well that was the
Hulk was a very terrestrial character
and then thor ragnarok he went to space
so there's a Hulk vs. venom comic you
could very easily maybe do that in space
which could be super fun and then you
throw Thor in the mix there's so many
worlds colliding oh yeah and like Hulk
vs. venom would actually be kind of cool
on a conceptual level too because they
both have a similar kind of thing where
there's the human version and there's
the presence that takes over
and even though venom I get the sense is
way more controllable than at least the
MC use Hulk that current even still
there's a certain unwieldy quality to
both of those characters I think would
be interesting to watch kind of mirror
themselves this earthquake one though
is the best one I definitely definitely
hope we get an MCU movie where the
villain is just a guy taking credit for
natural disasters whose has the worst
name ever
oh oh was this the same one yeah captain
bad vibes yeah ever dr. dr. bad vibes
which is good job because that's a thing
as to is you know we're gonna start
running out of the recognizable villains
and the thing that excites me about
comic book movies is when they take the
weirder or more out-of-the-box stuff and
bring it to light yeah you know which is
why like I'm really excited that DC is
gonna start producing some standalone
like weird offshoot movies and things
you know like MCU they put in Howard the
Duck in that one guardians movie why
can't we get dr. bad bones or at least a
nod I just wanted like a nod of some
kind actually Greg pitched do you ever
see those Daryl webisodes and lead up to
thor ragnarok related yeah his roommate
like that would be a perfect place to
have a dr. bad vibes storyline then I'm
the nun
I think venom the nun could be cool
again they've already made that movie
it's called the nun yeah foreshadowing
this whole cinematic you the conjuring
really ties in yeah it's it's important
especially if you're gonna go out venom
watch all-economy this is the thing that
makes me feel like in an alternate
universe there could be like a venom TV
show because like this is the wacky kind
of [ __ ] that you can have venom do on a
TV show I think a lot of times superhero
and comic book characters work better in
that TV format just because you know
these stories have been told through so
many different volumes of comic books
yeah it just makes sense to do it
episodically yeah it does it really does
actually okay in all seriousness the one
of these that I thought could actually
make a pretty cool movie is I don't know
that much about the Flash Thompson venom
stories but this one where he's like a
coach and then one of his students kind
of gets some of the symbiote on them and
then becomes their own character you
know like I thought that could be an
actual cool like side story if they
wanted to start producing side stories
you know one I think that could even
work with the Peter Parker like within
the spider-man universe oh yeah that's
cool
what if that's
the character that Sunday is playing I
don't know I think it's a cool concept
have an idea that kid becomes this
villain because they get infected by the
symbiote so I don't know I think that
would be really really neat thing to see
within the Marvel Universe of everything
and also I love the idea of the Marvel
characters and the Marvel heroes having
to fight a child because that like
brings in even more levels of your world
so yeah I don't care I'll punch a kid
that would be yo ya know all bets are
off I love it just as much you know and
actually the underground city think too
is is not that this at all happens this
way in the movie but I thought that they
did kind of actually nod to this and I
know the movie is based pretty well on
the lethal protector books yeah I don't
know venom he seems to have a soft side
you know and I appreciate a good good
villain you know gotta have a little
dynamic a little dimension you know
those are the best balance the villains
that either have this offsider this
others you know version of them or the
villains that you're like wait I kind of
agree with their reasoning oh yeah like
I would kill my team Loki ah yeah yeah
Loki that makes sense yeah and come on
girls well as another great ones like
you notice you're like on board which
like now I get it
a lot of notches though so you've killed
a lot of people so it's not really on
board other nerds do yeah great yeah I
don't know I mean I wouldn't be
surprised if we at least see versions of
any of these idea I mean maybe not like
the none one for example but yeah I
wouldn't be surprised if we saw some of
these fire or high frequencies but you
can completely kill the symbiote you can
completely kill it from what I
understand at least it you know as of
the movie and the little comics I've
seen if it's deprived for long enough
the actual just like GUI form it will
die okay you can destroy one it's just
hard gotta get around all those teeth
man and you know what else you you know
it's hard to destroy his Derek Mitchell
patron of the day you know if there's
anybody very liable to run into a
situation a lot like this you know may
run afoul of some secret tech or
something as Derek Mitchell yes
patron of the day Derek Mitchell because
Derek Mitchell just got a new job at a
tech company I was kind of vague about
that so you know I mean Derek Mitchell
is the guy behind the computer now yeah
he's typing up things you never know
what he's in control of you know maybe
he's in control of the locking
mechanisms that keep all kinds of crazy
experiments inside he's the guy in the
chair man he's Ned it's been an honor
spider-man would help sir Don or gang
Keely if you want to go you like comic
book accurate yeah
well Derek we're counting on you to keep
our safety in check
please don't let anything I don't know
like I got a sinister vibe and I just I
want you to be safe alright well I hope
he's not working for supervillain
hopefully you never know because they
always come across especially when they
own laboratories and businesses they
always come across super polished you
know they always come across really
affable don't let yourself get suckered
in Derek alright do what's right be the
hero and I'll see you guys can subscribe
to the reject nation hit that
notification bell to get updated every
time a review or a video is out cuz the
subscribe button doesn't work for that
and hit us up on patreon would love to
have you become a patreon object over
there we've got lots of cool stuff and
be sure to check out Keaton Markie on
the social medias on the interwebs
you're you you do all sorts of stuff so
just keep your eyes peeled you'll see
you gonna slow down again anytime soon
hey if you follow me on social media
you'll definitely know if I do if and
when I do make it happen people peace